[Musique]
alors le mardi d'habitude c'est
l'environnement et on vient d'en parler
avec jean-jousel mais avec vous Valérie
ce soir on va parler innovation une fois
n'est pas coutume voilà via le logiciel
de modélisation modéliot créé par
l'entreprise SOFTEAM une entreprise
Guillan courtoise en 1991 enfin créée
par vous Philippe Defy bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous ce soir donc vous êtes
directeur recherche et développement au
dans l'entreprise en 1991 donc vous
créez ce ce
logiciel un logiciel précurseur dans
dans le domaine pourquoi cette création
pourquoi ce besoin ben chaque chaque
domaine d'ingénierie a besoin d'un
modèle c'est vrai de la mécanique c'est
vrai de de la CAO c'est vrai du bâtiment
et le logiciel qui est un domaine tout
récent a dû maturer très rapidement et
c'est en dans les années 80 que sont
venus les les les premières utilisations
de modèles et et comme on est dans un
domaine je dirais théorique c'est-à-dire
par exemple un programme complexe peut
faire des millions de lignes de code on
a besoin de de maîtriser cette
complexité et les modèles nous aident à
maîtriser cette complexité alors au-delà
de nous aider à maîtriser les
complexités c'est-à-dire à comprendre ce
qu'on veut faire ce qu'on va bâtir et et
comment ça s'organise on peut utiliser
les modèles pour vérifier pour simuler
avant de de de consacrer une énergie
folle à faire des millions de lignes de
code
pour un projet final et puis on peut
aussi utiliser les modèles pour produire
automatiquement du code c'està-dire pour
automatiser le travail de développement
et cette automatisation pardon Catherine
cette automatisation n'existait pas
auparavant c'est
ça dans les logiciels c'est quelque
chose de relativement nouveau disons que
c'est c'est apparu dans les années
beaucoup dans les années 90 elle
existait pour certains types de modèles
mais dans des niches assez précises
d'accord moi j'aV j'avais juste une
question de béenne pardon par je son les
spéci iste en plateau quand vous dites
code c'est-à-dire c'est les un logiciel
ça ça permet de faire
fonctionner une application une
application et et donc pour construire
un logiciel il faut rédiger des
programmes qui se traduisent par des des
des milliers des millions de de ligne de
code d'accord là c'est clair d'accord
parfait et alors comment on en vient un
beau matin à à à se dire bah il faut que
je crée quelque chose pour pour
faciliter le travail des développeurs et
bien on en vient par la pratique en
rencontrant la difficulté et puis aussi
en transposant des choses qui existaient
ailleurs euh ce qui existait avant
c'était par exemple sur les base de
données il y a il y avait des modèles
euh dédiés aux bases de données il y
avait d'autres modèles dédiés à des
aspects dynamiques mais tout ça très
séparés dans des domaines très
différents et euh avec l'avénnement de
ce qu'on a appelé les langages à objets
euh par exemple Apple rank zerox sont
sont des gens qui ont mis en valeur les
langages à objets les systèmes
multifenétrés dont on est tous familiers
maintenant sont le résultat de de ces
langages à objets les langages à objets
ont reposé le problème de de de comment
on peut les représenter et maîtriser la
complexité et la la combinaison des
modèles appliqués à ces nouveaux
paradigmes euh a donné une puissance
nouvelle euh au modèle et nous a donné
aussi une une proximité plus proche
entre modèle et et le langage de
programmation alors pour résumer hein
l'histoire de ce logiciel nous allons
voir un sujet puisque nous nous sommes
rendus au sein de l'entreprise softteam
et nous allons découvrir euh ce logiciel
sous les images de elodim moine vous
n'imaginez pas faire un bâtiment sans
modèle vous ne pourriez pas imaginer de
mettre sans ouvrier avec des paquets de
briques et de ciment et de dire allez-y
construisez le bâtiment sans modèle
d'accord une parabole qui pourrait
s'appliquer au modèle informatique car
bien des logiciels ne fournissent pas de
modèles concrets aux développeurs qui
travaillent en aveugle fort de ce
constat l'entreprise softteam précurseur
en la matière a donc créé le logiciel
modelo il s'adapte adapte aux
interlocuteurs et au cœur de métier et
permet de donner une vue différente à
chacun si on a un modèle trop technique
face à un utilisateur ou un manager le
dialogue ne va pas se produire et donc
partant de ces modèles on on assemble
les vu de chacun et ça nous permet de de
de descendre jusqu'à la réalisation du
du développeur ces modèles permettent
aussi de générer des codes
automatiquement d'éviter ainsi les
erreurs humaines et de faire des
contrôles de cohérence des fonctions qui
apportent un vrai en terme de
productivité et d'emploi la création de
ce logiciel dont Philippe desfrais est
l'inventeur a engendré le succès de Sof
team de par le monde l'entreprise
Guillant courtoise emploie aujourd'hui
personnes alors on l'a vu dans le sujet
un modélio permet de de générer des
codes de manière automatique mais aussi
voilà de d'éviter les les erreurs
humaines qu'est-ce qu'il apporte quel
est le plus qu'il peut apporter aux
entreprises aujourd'hui maîtriser la
complexité
euh aider à assurer la qualité et puis
augmenter la productivité donc ça c'est
important parce que par exemple
l'offshore est un terme relativement à
la mode sauf que l'offshore a de pose de
grandes difficultés le premier c'est
déléguer un travail pour le déléguer il
faut le définir précisément et être
capable de l'expliquer c'est pas si
simple surtout avec des cultures
différentes dans différents pays et puis
le deuxième c'est être sûr que les les
différents sous-traitants qui font des
parties ABC euh travaille bien en en
coordination et en cohérence euh si on
n' pas de modèle rien ne le garantit et
et les surprises arrivent à la fin
évidemment au plus mauvais moment la
première version de modelo est née en
1991 il y en a eu
d'autres comment a-t-elle abouti alors
oui parce que
d'abord d'abord Modelio a adressé de
plus en plus de domaines euh a dû
évoluer face à des standards par exemple
au début nous avons inventé le modèle
qui à l'époque s'appelait class relation
puis il y a eu d'autres concurrents dans
le monde puis il y a eu un effort de
standardisation qui s'appelle UML qui
est très connu maintenant donc nous
sommes allés à l'OMG aux États-Unis et
l'Institut de standardisation pour bah
apporter nos connaissances voir où all
est le standard et l'influencer de sorte
que nous avons été précurseurs dans
certaines technologies du ML et que donc
c'est un standard actuellement
extrêmement reconnu et et répandu alors
comment on fait alors oui voilà comment
on fait petite entreprise au départ
Guillon cortoise et pour évoluer comme
ça de par le monde euh ben je crois
qu'il faut se battre donc il faut
décrocher des des clients rencontrer des
gens qui ont le problème essayer
d'utiliser cette première cette premier
ce premier succès pour en convaincre
d'autres essayer de faire boule de neige
et puis se battre avec des instruments
classiques le marketing le commercial et
ça c'est facile alors quand on quand on
s'appelle sof team et qu'on porte pas
d'autres noms disons prestigieux comme
Microsoft ou IBM c'est très difficile et
d'abord il y a une force de frappe qui
est sans comparaison donc ça c'est
extrêmement difficile et puis bien sûr
il y a toute la difficulté qu'on a pour
n'importe quel produit àier l'idée
technologique au marketing aux aspects
financiers au commercial il faut allier
des des compétences pas facil est-ce
qu'on peut protéger une invention de ce
type bah enfin nous on est loin d'être
protégé d'abord il y a pas de brevet
logiciel en Europe donc pas de
protection sur ce qu'on fait ensuite les
connaissances ont été mises au niveau du
standard donc le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que tout le monde peut les
utiliser et ensuite on a une édition
open source de notre produit donc on
travaille pas tellement sur la
protection à part le nom la marque qui
est déposée en Europe et aux États-Unis
mais pour le reste il y a pas de
protection et vous avez des concurrents
on oui il y en a deux que tout le monde
connaît qui s'appelle IBM et Microsoft
et puis c'est pas rien et puis puis il y
en a d'autres il il y a oui il y a pas
mal de concurrents sur ce secteur alors
vous êtes largement agrandi et le succès
de SOFTEAM serait en partie du à ce
logiciel pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
parce que il a il y a eu quand même des
évolutions radicales en informatique
qu'on connaît tous internet des langages
comme Java les langages objets les les
architectures SOA ce genre de chos le
Cloud Computing et j'en passe donc
l'innovation est un point décisif pour
pénétrer et face
souvent des décideurs qui informatiqu
qui sont un peu en désarroi parce que
ils perdent leur anciennes méthodes
leurs anciennes habitudes et donc ils
s'appuie sur nous sur nos connaissances
et notre maîtrise pour bah pour
envisager l'avenir et faire leurs
évolutions très bien une dernière
question non ah ben une dernière
question sofam recrute oui sofam recrute
précisément nous cherchons des personnes
sur qutin pour pour augmenter notre
équipe de de raid quel type de profil ce
sont toujours des gens qui qui ont bac
plus 4 ou 5 donc qui sortent de de
niveau Master 2 ou ingénieurs de
spécialisé informatique qui connaissent
par exemple Java UML ou ce genre de
choses d'accord ben merci en tout cas
Philippe d'êre d'être venu sur sur ce
plateau et raconter la belle histoire de
de Sofy moi je trouve c'est une très
très belle histoire une petite
entreprise VI en courtoise qui qui
maintenant rivalise avec les avec les
géants très belle histoire et pour finir
Valée on va repasser dans alors on passe
environnement façon on va revenir à
l'environnement avec deux dates ouce
l'environnement c'est quand même
important donc à partir d'aujourd'hui la
Maison de l'environnement propose une
exposition réalisé avec des enseignants
chercheurs de cinq établissements
différents universitaires tous en
coopérative hein c'est le titre de cette
exposition qui permet de découvrir le
développement des coopératives à travers
l'histoire l'économie et de voir les
différentes formes de coopératives
existante l'exposition se déroule
jusqu'au 31 janvier et puis pour ceux
qui ont la main verte une démonst
stration de taille de poirier et arbre
de plein vent est organisé samedi 8
décembre à 14h au verger du musée de
Port Royal des des champs à Manil et à
mot l'entrée est libre mais la
réservation elle est indispensable voilà
merci Vale pour toutes ces informations
on vous retrouve mardi prochain pour une
nouvelle chronique environnement
environnement environnement et puis à
partir du 14 décembre je le rappelle
pour le magazine équilibre et puis avant
de cequ un autre sujet environnement
vous allez nous nous présenter vos
nouveaux amis qui portent de jolis noms
comme Roger flocon encore exactement nos
nouveaux amis Catherine tout à fait dans
le cadre de la Semaine européenne nous
les avons rencontré au centre de loisir
les quatre arbre à hlencour le centre de
loisir qui organisait une journée
justement respect de l'environnement et
réduction des déchets sur les images
toujours d'é l' d' moine donc le
composteur il est là-bas qu'est-ce qu'on
peut pas mettre dedans une peau de
banane ou d'orange ou alors des pelures
[Musique]
d'oignon question qui mérite réflexion
et finalement ben on met toutes les
épluchures qu'on qu'on a fini et après
on les met
dans ce petit quiz s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la Semaine européenne de la
réduction des déchets auquels ce centre
de loisirs d'élencour a souhaité
participer tout au long de l'année on a
déjà on a un potager on a un potager on
fait du compost voilà naturel on a aussi
des des animaux à l'intérieur au sein
même du centre de loisirs les animaux en
question les voici flocon et clafouti en
intérieur et Roger qui gambade dans la
cour on change sal les tire des fois et
on on met dans le
compost les activités du centre de
loisirs sont particulièrement axées sur
l'environnement et le développement
durable question de sensibilité des
animateurs qui transmettent cet intérêt
aux enfants ici ces derniers leur propre
confiture et s'occupent du potager ce
jour-l l'activité Ren c'est le compost
le convoi exceptionnel dirige la
brouette jusqu'à son but final on la
litière de Roger dans dans le
composteur pour quoi faire pour pour
faire pour que ça fasse de l'engraé et
qu'ensuite on pe on puisse les mettre
dans la dans les plantes reste plus qu'à
attendre 6 à 12 mois la durée moyenne du
compost